en este vídeo voy a hablar acerca de los
bonos los bonos y es que realmente este
es un gran paso para construir todo el
conocimiento que queremos aprender un
bono esencialmente es una forma de
invitar a alguien que participe
prestándole dinero a una compañía o
dicho de otra manera cuando tú tienes un
bono te conviertes en un prestamista
parcial prestamista parcial y bueno yo
creo que para hacerlo desde un principio
mucho más ameno voy a verlo con un
ejemplo supongamos que nosotros somos
una empresa que tiene de activo 10
millones de pesos entonces nuestro
activo son 10 millones de pesos y además
está genial porque no tenemos deuda es
decir no tenemos pasivo esto quiere
decir que entonces tenemos de capital
también 10 millones de pesos recuerda
que el capital lo podemos construir como
el activo menos el pasivo por lo tanto
nuestro capital también es de 10
millones de pesos muy bien ahora lo
siguiente que vamos a suponer es que
esta empresa tiene también acciones y va
a tener un millón de acciones ojo si
tenemos un millón de acciones y tenemos
de total de activo 10 millones por lo
tanto cada acción va a valer
entonces 10 pesos por acción tengo un
millón de acciones y entonces el
problema va a consistir en lo siguiente
nosotros como empresa queremos crecer
por lo tanto se me ocurre poner una
nueva fábrica pero esta fábrica me
cuesta 5 millones de pesos como voy a
conseguir 5 millones de pesos quien me
los va a financiar bueno esta es la
pregunta de los 5 millones de pesos y lo
primero que se me ocurre contarles es
que necesitamos aumentar nuestro activo
y una forma de aumentar nuestro activo
es aumentando nuestras acciones entonces
si nosotros tenemos que cada acción vale
10 pesos entonces yo el mito otras cinco
mil acciones cinco mil por diez me dan
cinco millones de pesos entonces en mito
otras cinco mil acciones a diez pesos
cada acción y así obtengo mis cinco
millones de pesos que necesitaba para
construir mi fábrica esa es una de las
opciones que yo tengo para financiar
esta fábrica por lo tanto vamos a
escribirlo para que quede todo muy claro
tengo 1.5 millones de acciones y esto va
a hacer que crezca mi capital y entonces
también va a crecer mi activo y en total
de acciones ya no tengo un millón de
acciones tengo 1.5 millones de acciones
qué
es mi activo entonces voy a tacharlo ya
esta forma de conseguir yo estos 5
millones de pesos para construir mi
fábrica no sé de chocolates para que sea
un problema dulce a esta forma de
conseguir estos 5 millones de pesos le
voy a poner el nombre de aumentar mi
capital de forma financiera o financiar
mi capital
financiar a través de mi capital
financiero a través de mi capital ya
está aquí y fíjense que de esta forma
emitiendo acciones logramos resolver el
problema ahora que otra opción tenemos
para financiar esta fábrica voy a dejar
la pantalla aquí para que puedan
comparar las dos formas de
financiamiento y entonces recuerden yo
tenía de activo 10 millones de pesos y
como no tenía deudas ésta era mi capital
entonces mi capital también es 10
millones de pesos y en esta ocasión lo
que voy a hacer es pedir dinero prestado
ojo en el caso anterior lo que yo hice
fue emitir acciones y con esto logré
financiar mi fábrica de 5 millones de
pesos
aquí lo que voy a hacer es pedir
prestado y para no quebrar nos la cabeza
de buscar quién me va a prestar estos 5
millones de pesos
el banco y el banco me ve decir como tú
eres una buena empresa ecológica que
siempre paga te voy a prestar 5 millones
de pesos por lo tanto ahora tengo una
deuda de 5 millones de pesos lo que
significa que tengo un pasivo de 5
millones de pesos y sin embargo ya tengo
mi fábrica que cuesta 5 millones de
pesos por lo tanto mis activos se ven de
la misma manera tengo ya mi fábrica de 5
millones de pesos ahora la diferencia
entre esta forma de ver las cosas y la
que estamos viendo ahorita es la
siguiente en la primera forma de
financiamiento nosotros obtuvimos este
dinero aumentando el número de
accionistas ojo es decir la gente a la
cual le tenemos que dividir mis
ganancias de esta compañía en la segunda
forma de financiamiento obtuvimos el
dinero de una deuda monetaria dinero
prestado de una monetaria que está
escrito y en este caso vamos a pagar el
interés de este préstamo sin embargo las
ganancias de la empresa seguirán siendo
nuestras ahora esto es una decisión
interesante porque si nuestra empresa le
va súper súper súper bien entonces
obtendremos muchas ganancias y el banco
solo le pagaremos su debido interés
mientras que de la otra manera se
repartirán las ganancias pero se obtiene
un riesgo menor pues si no nos va bien
en la empresa podríamos quedar en la
bancarrota ahora bien obtener un
préstamo no es una cosa difícil si uno
va a un banco y le dice somos una buena
empresa y el banco te ve como una
empresa saludable y una empresa que le
va a pagar entonces te va a prestar esos
cinco millones de pesos y tal vez estás
en una forma mucho más rápida de
conseguir el dinero en lugar de
conseguir accionistas sin embargo este
video se llama bonos introducción a los
bonos y no hemos utilizado esta palabra
entonces vamos a ver una tercera forma
de financiamiento y va a ser utilizando
bonos que por cierto si el banco no los
quiere prestar el dinero por cualquier
razón que ustedes se les ocurra va a ser
muy buena opción para obtener nuestra
fábrica que tanto queremos ahora bien
nosotros vamos a expedir estos bonos o
estos certificados y la primera pregunta
que yo me haría es que es un bono bueno
un bono tiene una apariencia más o menos
así este bono es de mil pesos y este va
a ser su famosísimo valor nominal valor
nominal es decir es el valor que aparece
en el certificado de este bono
que tiene una renta fija y por cierto
también necesitamos una tasa de interés
es decir que no obtenga este bono o un
cupón de este bono le vamos a pagar un
10% anual lo podemos decir de esta
manera vamos a obtener un 10% anual por
cada cupón que nosotros obtengamos de
este bono y cada cupón de este bono va a
valer mil pesos entonces voy a dibujar
supongamos que este es un cupón este es
otro este es otro etcétera y lo que
quiere decir todo esto es que nosotros
vamos a obtener por cada cupón 100 pesos
después de que transcurra un año pero
como se vea pero aquí nuestros cupones y
para descendientes este si modos mejor
los voy a borrar y voy a seguir con mi
idea del bono entonces este bono también
necesita una fecha de vencimiento y
vamos a ponerle nuestra fecha de
vencimiento lo que quiere decir esto es
que nosotros vamos a regresar los mil
pesos después de una cierta cantidad de
tiempo que en este caso va a ser dos
años la fecha de vencimiento son dos
años y ahora bien como nosotros queremos
obtener cinco millones de pesos pues
entonces necesitamos cinco mil bonos o
cupones de bonos porque cinco mil por
mil me dan cinco millones de pesos
entonces tengo 5000 de estos bonos y
bueno si tú eres una persona que cree en
esta compañía que quieres verla crecer y
además que se te hace que el 10 por
ciento de interés anual es una buena
tasa de interés entonces tú vas a
comprar 1 2 3 la cantidad de vemos que
tú quieras' pero lo que sí sería bueno
especificar es que cuando tú compres un
bono entonces tú le vas a dar a la
empresa mil pesos y así la empresa va a
buscar a las cinco mil personas para que
cada una de esas cinco mil personas les
dé mil pesos por cada bono y entonces
así consigas cinco millones de pesos
ahora bien vamos a seguir la idea de
cuentas claras amistades largas por lo
tanto voy a tratar de aclarar mucho
mejor qué es lo que va a pasar con dos
mil pesos entonces voy a hacer una línea
del tiempo y aquí va a ser el día de hoy
entonces voy a poner hoy y qué es lo que
va a pasar aquí le voy a poner seis
meses después va a pasar un año que son
doce meses después un año y medio que
son 18 meses y para finalizar los dos
años que son 24 meses lo primero que me
gustaría hacerles notar es que mi línea
del tiempo acaba en dos años porque esa
es mi fecha de vencimiento
y después lo que quiero hacerles notar
es cómo voy a recibir el dinero que voy
a obtener por darle a esa empresa mil
pesos dice voy a obtener el 10 por
ciento de interés anual es decir que por
cada año voy a obtener 100 pesos por
cada año voy a obtener 100 pesos eso he
dicho de otra manera quiere decir que
los primeros seis meses voy a obtener 50
pesos en los siguientes seis meses voy a
obtener 50 pesos y date cuenta como 50
más 50 me dan los 100 pesos en un año en
los siguientes seis meses 50 pesos y en
los últimos también 50 pesos así que en
total voy a obtener 100 pesos por cada
año y al finalizar los 2 años la empresa
me tiene que regresar 10 mil pesos que
le preste originalmente y bueno lo que
suele suceder es que si nuestra empresa
no tiene el dinero para pagar a cada una
de las cinco mil personas dos mil pesos
entonces se recurre a algún nuevo tipo
de bono porque es una suma enorme de
dinero y de estos de lo que hablaremos
en el siguiente vídeo